[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
now
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what is popping everyone i am your host
justin woodward co-founder of the mix
the media indie exchange and team in
terra bank entertainment as well as lead
advisor on the humble black game
developer fund and black voice and
gaming welcome to the mix 10-year
anniversary edition of black voices and
gaming where we will be celebrating
amazing black developers and their games
i am joined with my homie and part of
the leadership squad of black voice and
gaming alfonzo hooker how is it going
what's going on
um my name is alfonso hooker i am
co-founder of black voices and gaming
and also tech perfect which is a
consulting company focused on uh
leadership and development opportunities
for women in poker color intent that's
what's up yeah i mean this is going to
be an amazing showcase we have some
developers we have some interviews this
is live so i may be talking to our folks
out here um you guys got to turn the the
music down a little bit in my headphones
um but yeah the the mix showcase was was
pretty good um and we do have a great
lineup of uh black developers and
industry professionals who will be
having conversations with and sharing
their games
yeah and a little bit about uh black
voices in gaming it was created back in
2020 of june during the protests and
demonstrations that united us all over
the world we have been working on black
voice and gaming over the past two years
and transformed it from a broadcast
showcase into a movement where we not
only share developers games but we are
also now a non-profit that is set up to
accelerate the growth of professional
game developers and our mission is to
help game studio entrepreneurs by giving
them introductions to funding resources
publishers press and mentors that will
help them succeed so maybe we could just
chop it up a little bit and talk about
what what we've kind of been up to yes
so past two years we've been putting
this together and really focusing on um
the pipeline for all of the developers
that we've been working with we have
amazing developers on the show uh we had
tony barnes and all these folks we've
been connected with and what we've seen
is that there's been these gaps in
funding resources
marketing publishing and
through some of the networks that justin
has put together his his work with
humble and all the other organizations
were partnered with is essentially
taking this
idea and turned it into a full-fledged
non-profit that we're actually going to
be funding these these games and these
amazing black voices that we're going to
be featuring
yeah and i mean like i said we started
this in 2020 during the civil unrest i
as a black game developer is having a
lot of trouble finding funds mentorship
and that type of thing so now we're able
to extend that i mean humble's been very
awesome we've signed 28 games there i've
worked been working with xbox and
playstation which we're going to lead
into our sponsors too shout out to our
sponsors for today's showcase raw fury
who helped get the series started and is
helping with the funding for the series
uh throughout the year playstation
they've been amazing from day one razer
who we were working with through this
and the mix um yeah so where else can we
support the devs
we can support the devs all over i mean
we i think there's uh by
primarily going to the events page the
mix events page on steam going and
buying those games but also wishlisting
the games that are not available but
please check that box
check that box okay so to get started we
have a professional aaa game
programmer at sony san diego who is also
an advocate for black devs and indie
professionals we have kojo here um and
can you can we please turn the sound
down for spirit swap
oh wow hey everybody
hey hey kojo how's it going
not bad not bad good to see y'all happy
beer
and it's so it's uh super amazing that
you're here uh kojo you're such an
advocate for black game developers and
developers in general and you are just a
staple in the industry for being an
engineer and i think we should just get
started with a little bit of your
history i think people really want to
know um what you're about and what
you're actually doing at playstation
uh sorry i think it froze a little bit
for me i might have missed your first
question
oh yeah so just tell us a little bit
about yourself and and how you got into
game development and what you do at uh
at playstation
absolutely yeah yeah so uh i'm uh my
current title is gameplay programmer and
i'm based in san diego
um i was working with san diego studios
and i'm with a different organization
there now and i've been a game developer
since 2008 actually started my career in
new york city i went to school at nyu i
studied
computer science and cinema studies
there was no game center there at the
time so i didn't have like a game
program to study but what's interesting
is my second job out of school i
actually worked at a small company
called area code that was founded by
frank lance who was the founder of the
nyu game center so actually working with
him i was able to go to a lot of those
talks and whatnot uh over the years and
get kind of um enmeshed in the new york
like game scene and i was really into
that stuff like all those academic
discussions and whatnot so
did that for years when indie slash
freelance for a few years moved out to
san diego i was an iga organizer for a
while and now i'm at playstation
now what are you currently working on
right now
uh i'm definitely not at liberty to say
but i can say that it's awesome
and uh once it is released i will be
telling everybody but uh i'm excited
about the work that i'm doing right now
it's different than anything else let me
share that with us first though right
you you'll be notified you'll be
notified
what have you worked on before what are
some of the uh the past titles that
you're you're super proud of
being a developer on
yeah like i've worked on a wide variety
of things you know like again i started
my career in my casual web game so we
were making a virtual worlds and flash
worked on a bunch of facebook games when
i was freelancing i worked on a really
interesting project it was a citizen
science project for connectomics to help
map the brain so the idea there is they
had uh data from a
a mouse um cerebrum and you would scan
it and actually identify different parts
of it to see if you could track the um
the tubes of it in 3d uh i worked on a
really cool transformers boxing game for
mobile that was the first unity game i
ever worked on
uh at sony san diego i worked on the mlb
the show franchise for many years and
that was really really cool
that was my first time doing server
programming as well i got super deep
into that uh but ironically i think the
game i might be most proud of was a
political game i made during the 2016
presidential cycle it was a whack-a-mole
game
called bop the bigot where it was just
kind of tongue-in-cheek
you would hit uh trump joe arpaio and uh
david duke with a with a chocolate like
a mexican slipper
and uh did it with this uh that's
non-profit those organizing voter
registration arizona and it got got a
little traction and that was a lot of
fun to work on
so i really like that that's dope so
like how because you so you jumped into
aaa you've been into
um independent game development like
what what do how do you like that kind
of
mix mixture of development like solo and
you know as opposed to doing big game
studio work
no for sure i feel like i've talked to
my peers about this kind of recently i
felt like when i was an independent i
learned a tremendous amount because i
had to
and that was really interesting to go
really wide in terms of my skills and my
interest but at a triple a studio on a
really big team you know you go really
deep on something specific you know
you're not just the gameplay programmer
you know you might be focused on
animation or combat or inventory etc so
i definitely appreciate both experiences
i've done a lot of work on smaller teams
and individually but i like being on
bigger teams now where i can really dive
deep on something specific
nice nice
now i think that one of the uh things
that's
super important that we want folks to
understand is like how did you like
how do you get in to a game like
becoming a game developer what was sort
of sort of your journey into that sort
of thing because like there's tons of
folks out here want to actually become
developers don't know how actually how
hard it is to actually build a game
because i think people don't understand
that it's it's not easy
at all
absolutely yeah no making games is hard
uh i would definitely say uh and it's
different now than when i started in
2008 definitely like when when you
started justin
there's so many more schools and
programs now there's so many free
engines now so ironically i think that
making a game has become easier than
ever because they're really tools that
are readily available
i'm not sure if it's necessarily gotten
easier to get into the industry but i'll
say what worked for me and what i still
recommend for people is to find a
community
so uh the ig day was that for me igda
new york i went to an event it was
interesting i never heard people talk
about like game development and design
that way at the end of the event i met
two individuals both of them gave me a
business card i ended up interning for
one of them and that was basically my
foot in the door you know so when i came
to san diego again i didn't really know
anybody here so i became involved in the
local iga community we organized regular
mixers every month uh two three game
jams a year through that i was able to
find some freelance work it's not the
way that i ended up working at sony but
it was definitely a way for me to build
a community here and i get to know a lot
of other developers and i got some
freelance work through it so i would
definitely say the first thing i would
recommend if you're interested in games
is to find a community of people that
are interested in making games if you
have one locally at your school
uh or in your town and if you don't have
one then you should start one
um start a video game development club
uh there's so many places you can find
digitally as well discords itch.io and
then the next thing would just be to
make a game do a gamejam you know just
try to make something over a short
amount of time and just realize you know
what it takes how hard it is and if it's
something that you want to do because
sometimes you know you go into a game
jam thinking you're going to make you
know world of warcraft and then by
saturday afternoon you have like
a box moving left and right you're like
okay well let's see what we can actually
get
that's hilarious
gta you know what's really interesting
though is i think that you really
touched on something is
you sometimes we have to create our
communities
and i'm a big advocate for that because
i actually did the same thing fresh out
i went to art institute and as you know
in san diego there's like rockstar san
diego there's sony there was a couple
other studios and there was like
qualcomm and i was like i want to do
independent stuff i want to be creative
with what with what i'm doing and i
didn't have there was no igda san diego
happening i couldn't figure out how to
connect with professionals so i
basically did the same thing i was like
yo let's do at pizza port and carlsbad
where all of those folks are at let's
have a beer i'm gonna make a flyer right
and like
i think we definitely like that's a
really really good point is like you
can't
you can't always wait
you know for a group to pop up or the
best opportunity
yeah you have to build a community
create your community and
and uh kind of like as a segway to
another part of the conversation that i
wanted to have with you is i mean you're
actually doing that right now um and if
you're comfortable talking about it with
playstation right like we've been in
communication to help developers and
that's big and it's because there needs
to be support can you kind of talk about
the strides that you're taking
to help out developers
yeah absolutely so you know i've
definitely been an advocate for game
developers and game developer
communities since i was an iga organizer
in san diego and when i started working
at a playstation in san diego i stayed
in the igda group for a little while
then i moved away from that and started
becoming a part of something that at the
time was called pan at playstation
that's the playstation african-american
network and honestly playstation that
was my first like corporate gig i never
worked at like a really big company
before that so i found out there's
something called dei diversity equity
and inclusion and i think these things
are fairly recent so we have these um
employee resource groups they're called
employee networks now and their way to
get together with different folks in the
company with particular affinities and
to be totally honest i just wanted more
black friends at work so i was like oh
yeah pan i'll join that cool so i find
that
you know i met a lot of cool people in
different parts of the company with
different experiences and it was just
really really cool to hear um people's
experiences because you know as you guys
know
there's just so few black people in tech
and in games uh in general you know like
there's all kinds of challenges you face
in this country you know for
a wide variety of reasons and again
making games is difficult getting hired
is difficult so when you find other
people's similar experiences you're like
wow like how did you get here you know
and there's so much that you can like
resonate with them about that
so uh i was really into paying i was
really into the community we had there
and we just wanted to kind of expand and
keep doing activities and doing things
to advance our careers doing things to
you know celebrate our culture and doing
things to connect with the broader sony
group and other like-minded di groups so
i've been involved in that for several
years the role i kind of slid myself
into was a community outreach because
i'm sort of an outgoing person anyway
i've done other community organizing and
uh the main uh i guess endeavor i've
been championing lately has been this
thing called the new visions project
where
me and some other folks have been really
trying to support more black game
developers on the playstation platform
and really concrete specific ways and
trying to identify opportunities to
connect with developers to offer them
information offer them guidance offer
them resources and just kind of help
shepherd them along the process of being
successful developers because again
in addition to not knowing how to get
into the industry once you're in
sometimes you don't even know what to do
you know sometimes you don't know who to
ask how to get on a certain platform you
don't know how to ask for money you
don't know how to you know create a
business or have a thriving business and
i feel fortunate enough to be in a
position where i i've learned some of
that information i have access to people
who can answer those questions so i
think through some of the di and
connection work that i've been doing
with justin you know i think we want to
try to spread more of this information
and make an effort to allow other people
to be successful
yeah for sure yeah it does seem
sometimes like it's a black box
especially for everyone and then folks
who really do not have
uh the opportunities or access it's like
you definitely need kind of a lead in so
it's it's awesome what you're doing and
it's great to work on some of this stuff
um if you're comfortable chatting about
it what what do you what are some of the
obstacles you have had as a black game
professional in in the aaa space
i mean it's it's really hard to say you
know like again like making games is
hard you know being a
a black male in america is hard
so like it's hard for me to think of any
like specific specific cross sections
with that but one thing that i think i
can speak to easily is just
not necessarily feeling as though um i'm
completely understood or recognized you
know um in the way i communicate and the
experiences that i have and that can
just be a challenge with communication
you know if your leadership or your team
members you know don't have similar
experiences like you don't look like you
they don't kind of understand where
you're coming from it can make
everything more difficult and that's not
to say anything specific about the team
i'm on right now but i feel as though
there have been times in my career where
i feel as though um the challenge in
communication was part cultural
and that uh that just kind of comes with
the territory i think that there's maybe
a handful of instances where i felt like
this is like this has gone a little left
so i think that
with that the challenge again for me has
always been to try to focus on
how do i ensure my success and how do i
not get caught up in um
in any kind of situation
or any kind of um
conflict that could detract from what
i'm trying to achieve ultimately like i
know i'm trying to be successful in my
career i'm trying to advance i'm trying
to work on cool stuff i'm trying to you
know get paid i'm trying to be a game
developer you know so like if i feel
like i come across something that's
gonna try to detract from that i'm gonna
do whatever i can to move around it
and definitely having a community helps
for that you know like having black at
playstation and like those co-workers
that you can just kind of like rap with
and talk with once a while and just
really like relax it can really make um
make you more comfortable at the place
where you're at so that's something i'm
very thankful for um
in terms of being a black developer
yeah that's i mean that's true just
trying to keep your nose clean sometimes
in that capacity it's just like yo i
gotta maneuver the bs uh just get my
work done so i know i i totally feel
that a lot of i think a lot of times it
is that it's not like
overt craziness yeah but there's
isolation yeah sometimes isolation or
just trying to figure out how to you
know maneuver
um navigate to space yeah for sure
absolutely that's awesome
kojo um
i really i come from the sort of the
hardcore tech side the back end so you
said you did some stuff on the server
side what was what was that uh that
experience like say going from like just
traditional
game development but doing actual like
server server programming
so it's it's wild it was really like the
perfect transition for aaa as far as i'm
concerned because i started my career
making flash games so those are
necessarily on the web and we are making
multiplayer games so i started out as a
client programmer so i had a concept of
how network programming works and
apparently like a lot of people don't
start in that way and i didn't realize
that i just sort of took it for granted
so i'd actually done a lot of like
network programming and stuff and then
um when i was freelancing i worked on a
multiplayer uh
vr title so i had done end to end a
little bit but it was like um like a
peer-to-peer thing so you didn't have to
do any authoritative work so uh baseball
when i got hired for them it was
actually on the online services team
so they were rewriting their server in c
plus and a combination of c plus plus
and c sharp uh for our performance
reasons and for other internal reasons
and they were basically looking for
people to help them out to do that
because it was going to be this
monumental task
so really i think they were interested
in me because of my c-sharp experience
because i've done a lot of unity work
but when i went freelance it was really
an opportunity for me to dive into c
plus and learn that i had never done any
c plus what plus plus work
professionally i'd all been self-taught
so i think once you know i passed the
technical interview and they got me in
there they're like oh this guy can write
some c plus plus two so what was
interesting about it is since the nature
of the work was so rote and there was so
much of a volume of it for me
it was like this is a time to practice c
plus plus so i gotta rewrite all these
services and the old language the new
language i got to make sure they're fast
you know i got to make sure that
it's written safely because crashing is
always bad but when you crash on the
server you take down everybody
so i think like the experience of um
writing server code as opposed to
writing client code just had me thinking
about things differently it had me uh
becoming aware of issues that you don't
have to um think about on a client for
example and then also operational things
like if you have an issue with the data
while the game is live you know how do
you update
you know the database or whatever
without bringing the game down you know
because you want to avoid downtime just
different kinds of problems you have to
approach so i thought it was it was
incredibly uh informative for me and
also kind of an excellent way for me to
like
transition from the more casual side to
the aaa side with like the skills i had
and then also you know
build more skills that i could take
forward for other things
that's that's awesome and so now you're
doing more gameplay programming
yeah so i'm pretty much back on the
client side now which is i think where i
wanted to be ultimately
i can definitely do uh both ends of it
but i think that in my career i've had
most enjoyment enjoyment doing like
client-side stuff interactive stuff like
quicker reactive kind of things
awesome awesome well it's thank you so
much um for for joining us kojo it's
amazing having you and we're definitely
going to be talking more do you want to
kind of give a shout out about some of
the things that you're working on uh and
how to follow you
uh yeah you can definitely uh hit me up
on twitter did my video threes i'm not
sure if that's just from me um i think
so yeah
uh
yeah let's see
um
shucks well you can definitely hit me up
on twitter as twitter another kojo uh
you know um usually retweet memes
whatever i find interesting again once
my game is released i'm going to be
shouting it from the mountaintop so
you're definitely going to hear about it
uh but i think till then just kind of
stay tuned to the work that i'm going to
be doing with you justin black voices to
try to help other um black developers
maybe behind the scenes maybe in front
of it but you know i think staying tuned
to black voices and hopefully i'll be
able to contribute to that
yeah for sure thank you so much man it's
it's dope
yeah for sure
and kojo is is amazing
yeah um he's been
working with us on on figuring out our
programs and such
um it's great to see folks taking
strides to make a difference in in and
outside of like a corporate type of
setting um but we got a game coming up
all right yes next up we have chris
butler who has a colorful game with
amazing music titled spirit swap from
soft not weak let's check out the
trailer and then we're gonna hop into
the game and talk to christ
[Music]
make friends on the way and maybe you
can find your
[Music]
cause
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
we can swap spirits in the afternoon
spirit swap is
it's so gorgeous it's amazing that lo-fi
hip-hop vibe super dope we got chris
chris butler is on
what is happening chris it's so great to
have you
so thank you thank you
yeah yeah um so
this dude right here is going to play
spirit swap i don't think it's going to
be too crazy i think he's going to be
able to to kill it you know i mean
um can you tell
as we get into the game can you just
describe a little bit about the game the
gameplay and some of the influences
behind spirit swap
yeah so um
uh
our
our uh our creative director alex uh uh
is really into match three games and uh
as uh
you know early on in development um and
when i
when we formed uh
softnut week alex morgan and i uh we're
wanting to start with something small
but uh
we ended up you know building it up into
this uh match three game with a
narrative element and uh
basically it was just all the things
that we liked coming together in the
game uh just you know the music
colorful graphics as opposed to you know
kind of you know grim dark things that
are out there we wanted to have
something that was more
um
low stakes fun
colorful interesting characters
a game with a
really relaxing sort of gameplay
although
as we continue to develop and
develop two-player mode things get a
little competitive and maybe not so
so
down tempo but uh
uh yeah um i think a lot of the
inspirations are
uh mostly i guess
just kind of
us putting things that we like in the
game um
uh for example a lot of the designs of
the
environment and the characters are um
from uh alex's uh home country uh of
lebanon and uh pulling inspirations from
that and um
along with that um
just as
we put ourselves into the game like you
know the music that we like um which uh
i think early in development uh
you know it was the start of pain then
make we were inside locked in and
we
uh i i believe alex found our composer
multicannon um
and uh oh nice we're just like
this this music
i don't know it just
gave us life
you know um and so we were like we we
need to work with uh multicannon uh uh
to get
his sound and
uh influence in the game and
yeah
um but yeah it definitely slaps on a
chill on a like on a chill vibe you know
what i mean i don't know how if you
could say slaps on a chill vine but it
has
it has yeah it definitely has a vibe
like what
yeah when i first when i actually first
played it i just i i played it for some
time because i was just like so
inundated with work it just made me
chill it was funny was i i even turned
it off like i stopped playing the game
and i was working and i just kept the
game up
just like letting it loose
that's really cool i've done that myself
yeah
yeah what it what are some of the gains
that you pulled from like you know to
influence it i mean from from your
perspective i mean i see a little bit of
puzzle fighter i see a little bit of
yoshi's cookie like yeah you know yeah
um i think the the main
uh sort of inspiration was paneled upon
on uh
super nintendo which i think is also
known as tetris attack or pokemon puzzle
league and i think other oh yes titles
um yeah so
as far as mechanics um that's a a big
portion of uh the inspiration but we're
trying to add our own twist with um
spells um which uh i don't know if you
see there's a little gauge on the side
of the
the uh play field there if you see a
little emblem up here and you hit uh alt
uh or if you're on controller it might
be one of the buttons um you can cast a
spell that will clear
uh the top half of the machine so
[Laughter]
so that's the spell icon which
uh but
that's fine but um
but yeah we're trying oh what was that
okay cool that's awesome
yeah um so we're trying to mix it up
with uh that mechanic um
and we had different characters and um
also uh you can
as the game uh
in the main game there's a narrative
element and you'll uh get items you can
equip to get different spells and uh
or not items a quick but put in your
room to uh get different spells and that
kind of thing
that's cool
i think i'm gonna i'm gonna jump from
back from the game to you and back to
the game possibly i want to know a
little bit about your history and how
you got into
uh development and then you know help
the to be a part of this and start this
team
uh yeah um
so i guess uh
ever since i was little um
uh
i guess i guess yeah
starting from my dad was always into
computers so like i just in like that
kind of stuff so i'd been playing games
i'd been on a computer as early as i can
remember
and um
that being the case played a lot of
video games and wanted to know how to
make them um
so
yeah throughout my life um you know i
had been learning how to program my dad
had programming books so i'd try and
read them
but
actually career and
getting into into games in general i i
started off in animation um i went to
school and i studied the arts and
animation so
um
i
did that but actually i didn't go into
animation for some
about five years later because right out
of school i moved to japan um
and uh
at first i taught english and then i got
a job in an ad agency
and that's probably where i first
started using like programming because
uh for certain projects they would need
like web work and i would you know
doing basic things with javascript and
whatnot um i just was you know using it
on the job and and learning from there
and you know also in my free time uh and
i think uh
uh just as a previous guest had said uh
learn trying to make flash games i
learned a lot of action script which you
know is also kind of related to
javascript as well so
um yeah from there i i built up those
skills um
and uh after returning to the us
i was looking for work and uh
i was still uh doing some freelance web
design um and since i was mostly
self-taught i you know kind of didn't
have
uh
you know
the
i guess you know kind of the confidence
even though i had i may have had the
skills at the time so i i got a
certification and then from there um
yeah i
most of my gaming development work had
been in personal projects and things
like that
but
i had developed more kind of the
professional side of programming skills
with my work on web design and i did you
know
some
working at a startup i learned a little
bit of back end as well uh
um
making a mobile app um
and
uh
uh
working with the other team members uh
morgan and alex uh when we
i guess at first we're like hey you know
what we have a lot of skills here why
don't we try making a game
and uh
uh yeah and i guess
i guess that's
what brings us to spirit up today um
uh
yeah
that's cool you guys had a successful
yeah you guys had a successful
kickstarter
uh can you talk about kind of the
journey of developing this game because
i know it always is a journey from
development funding all that kind of
thing
right right um
so
yeah
we
had
you know started working on the game and
and i think perhaps
we were at a point where uh
uh it and i think the pandemic did have
a little bit of effect on it because
like we were just like indoors all the
time we're like what are we gonna do
with all this time let's
you know buckle down and make this game
and uh
and then we started and then we were
like all right and things started
picking up um
and you know we'd reached out to uh
multicannon and he agreed to help us
with the music
we had
reached out
to others to you know you know get help
on how to start a game and whatnot and
uh
yeah and then we were like i think it's
time to uh
do a kickstarter
and um
and
yeah we were you know asking around for
advice of what amounts we should start
with and whatnot and um we decided on an
amount of
75 000 uh dollars and a lot of people
were
maybe a little uh thinking maybe we
should you know bring the amount down
and
but that's the amount that we needed to
be able to you know properly pay
the people we want to work with and
invest in the things we need and
we
started the kickstarter and we doubled
our goal and made
150 000 which uh was that's so good
it's really good
because we uh
you know it's something that we put
ourselves into and it was really great
to see that you know so many other
people also
uh enjoy it as much as we do you know um
but yeah
yeah that's
that's really cool does so like can you
talk because i mean it's it's really
interesting that you said
uh that you were talking about you know
kind of that core philosophy of
paying your team correctly can you go
into that because i don't think every
you know every indie most indie studios
are like
fly by the seat of their pants and like
we'll figure it out but you you all are
really focused on making sure that
everybody is included and you know are
getting properly paid and that type of
thing
uh yes and we're structured as a
worker-owned co-op um so um wow
we're all we're all owners in this um so
we're trying to
um
to start off with making a co-op in the
u.s is quite tricky and that's a big
challenge that uh we've come up
against uh but we're working through it
and have a lot of uh great people uh to
get advice from but um yeah so
we want because right now we can't bring
all of our our contractors in but we are
we want to make sure that uh one that
while they are working for us that they
you know
can live on
you know the work that uh
that
we're doing together and
if when the game makes it we can you
know
you know i guess bring everyone
bring everyone in and be part owners as
well um
uh but yeah um it's really important for
us that uh you know soften up week uh
doesn't end up being like this entity
that
is just out for money um and that we you
know take care of uh you know the people
we work with
for sure
um i think i'm gonna play and then i'm
gonna i'm gonna turn it like he turned
it over to alfonso so i'm not bombarding
you with questions
the
the name of your studio soft not weak
where does that come from because it's a
very interesting name yeah
it speaks a lot to
what you guys are trying to build
um it's actually a
quote from the
sci-fi series farscape um
uh oh nice
i think not a direct quote but you know
it's definitely the core inspiration of
it and
i think it is a
an aspect that you know
you know
the world you know
i don't know a lot of times people are
like you know you got to be hard and
tough and you know
and all that kind of thing but
strength is not
necessarily about being like this tough
hard thing you know
so to speak you know it's like
you know you can be soft and strong or
you know soft didn't not
um a lot of martial arts are built on on
that as well right
not
rigid doesn't actually isn't stronger
so
it's good
and then just playing the game is one of
the things i thought was sort of really
amazing was like cuz i can play this
game for hours and not like
it's it's a it's a awesome
after work de-stress kind of game
because it's got like the
candy crush meets an r b mixtape the
sort of feel to it that i really really
love
and then i can just like play and chill
and like just vibe with the music and
and like do the matching and like and
then trying to get better at it uh
without like a bunch of anxiety like no
one's trying to shoot me or or run me
over or
and you know sometimes you need a break
from that especially
as a person of color in this role you
need a little uh something to distress
with so i think that's that's uniquely
important
yeah and even in the the narrative that
is being written for the game we didn't
want it to be like this big
you have to save the world or everyone
will die kind of thing it's just
you
prepping for a party
with your friends
oh is that it
that's awesome yeah can you can you kind
of can you go into the narrative because
that's really interesting i did not know
sure um yeah so
uh
i can
i actually i've not read too deeply
because i didn't want to spoil myself
but
but
but i do know like uh the the basic uh
outline of the game is uh uh summer here
is
um
uh can swap spirits um spirits are
actually uh beings from another
dimension and sometimes they cross over
and there's sort of an agreement between
uh
this dimension and the dimensionless
spirits to like if you find a spirit you
know um put them back together and then
send them back
and you can maybe also see that in the
animations a little bit um and then you
know send them back to the other
dimension but uh
there's something happening where there
are a lot of spirits around right now
and um that is one aspect of the story
you know not to spoil anything but also
um
uh i guess sort of the the flow of the
narrative is um
kind of uh like hades
it's not necessarily a
you know linear thing but as you visit
your friends uh the story develops and
um
you you know gain uh
you might gain some new spells new
furniture
or just have a very interesting uh
conversation with your friends um
and uh yeah you continue to progress in
the game get get more
you get you get it gets it's more
interesting you add more elements to the
game as you as you progress which is
great i mean i like i love that but it
doesn't it doesn't feel
uh what i call um
like stressful or like there's there's
no sort of build up of like oh i got to
get this thing done right now i don't
know i'm just i'm trying to swap these
things as fast as possible on this tiny
ass screen
only just did we find a find a way to
make this game
i can't like i can't stop from being
competitive i need to get these hearts
no i'm just kidding that's actually
something we've uh come across yeah like
even though you can go at your own pace
in chill mode um
we do have other modes that will scratch
that itch if you need something fast and
frenetic
so
yeah yeah i kind of went a little bit in
on it um
so you said they have a two-player mode
which uh
yeah
i was about to say oh it's gonna happen
you just put it down on your friends
okay yeah yeah yeah well you don't want
us to go on in we would we'd mess up
this whole interview
we wouldn't even be talking to you and
just be going in
um
you said you could get furniture like so
you could build out your like your
apartment or house or how does that work
that's awesome
so uh some are so it's kind of the
day-to-day uh life of summer and um it
you'll start in summer's room you know
prep for the day um
you can put on new clothes if you want
um
and also in your room you can decorate
it um
with different furniture and
uh depending on what you have in your
room uh it will affect game play as well
um
beyond that like
like
why this specific color palette and like
uh for the game
um
i think
an early development
as i mentioned earlier alex had
drawn some inspirations from their
from their home and they're
in there's a certain color palette that
is
similar to this uh that they uh
wanted in
particularly i believe these this blue
uh is a particular blue that alex wanted
in
um
and
yeah and i think just in general and
some
currently we do
in this demo there's this but
as you see other may see other scenes in
the future i think we did just want
colorfulness in general um just to
you know evoke you know joy
rather than
yeah
rather than any kind of it's not
not gloom and doom dark darkness of
space
so i have one last question so what is
um
like
it seems like this game is very
inclusive it's very colorful
how are you invoking that like the
diversity in this game
yeah um i would say um
our team
um i i i mentioned that a lot of this is
like uh our team putting themselves in
the game and uh yeah our team is a very
diverse group um
uh
and
and i think through that and maybe even
directly in some of the characters which
may be self-inserts in some ways um uh
that's great uh
i i think that
really comes through and i mean
it's just us kind of putting ourselves
in and wanting to see uh and
and i think also there are you know
other kids and kids other people maybe
kids um
who uh
um you know want to see people like us
in games and
for sure
we appreciate you jumping on chris this
is it's been amazing and i you know i've
been following the game i've been trying
to support it through like the black
game developer fun and that type of
thing um how could we find out more
about the game do you have any release
date
updates or
um yeah that type of thing
um yeah so release date the plan is q4
2022 later this year
um and if you want to follow development
uh
softnut week on twitter is uh
nice a great place to start and we also
have a discord
for uh following development as well if
you want to uh get to know even more
details about what's going on um also um
yeah we'd appreciate it if you wish list
wishlist us on steam and also uh uh
maybe also follow us on ichio
you can also get the demo there uh on
both uh steam and the chio
if you wanna if anyone out there wants
to play it
awesome absolutely thank you so much
chris and we'll definitely talk to you
again uh soon um definitely wish list
the game absolutely wish this game buy
the game q4 will be released and play
the demo play the demo yeah it's dope
you'll love the vibe of that game yeah
uh chris
soto uh it's great that that they were
able to jump on shout out to our
sponsors again raw fury playstation
razer
and everybody who's watching the stream
and the developers involved um coming up
next
is haboka a single player survival
horror video game based on folklore for
i don't know why i said video games
obviously it's a video game for
madagascar and center around the middle
of the 20th century from salem and his
team at flying carpet games let's check
out the trailer
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
that was the eerie trailer for hoboken
we have salem on the line what is up
sale how's it going
hi guys how are you guys doing
good i can't see your chin
i'm just okay and now i can see your
chin
just i'm just playing um
thank you thank you so much for joining
us did you just shave too i don't know
now i'm like all about the facial
features
uh yesterday just for you guys okay
thank you thank you i shave for you too
i can't yo i have to call it how it is
you know this is live now because i'm
talking this mess um yeah hoboken is so
awesome thank you for joining us i think
you're you know what's really
interesting is your story and where
you're from so i kind of want to before
we kind of before we get into game play
can you can you talk about a little bit
about your background as a developer and
where you're actually at where you know
um what country and and region you're
from
yeah so i'm uh canadian i'm from
montreal
my mother is from madagascar so uh you
can see how that plays into the game uh
my my father is french canadian
uh i've been in the gaming industry and
since 2008 i started at gameloft in uh
you know making a mobile game
and then i realized that i wanted to
make my own games i wanted it i wanted
to be indie so in 2012
i started to
my own studio flying carpets game
we did
a first video game the the girl on the
robot
that you can maybe you can see here that
was released on ps4
and also on steam uh also on wii u if
you guys remember the wii u
and then
we did a card game
and now i'm back in video game making my
second video game which is
a game that is a little bit more
personal because it it goes into
the culture from
my mother's side of the family so
the inspiration came a lot from the
story she told me
and then i started you know to uh
to research about the mythology about
folklore of madagascar and i i
discovered some pretty dark
things
uh you know
there was some good thing but there's a
lot of um you know um
things linked to the underworld and uh
and uh death
and so it it kind of tied in with the
story i wanted to tell of grief
so um
yeah basically in the game you play you
can play as two characters the first one
well the one that is playable now is
alexander
which
just lost his mother and he's trying to
find a way
uh to reconnect with her
uh with you know the
the
uh the
you can say
the the means of um
malgashi uh
witchcraft so
uh
kiboka the word imbuka is one of the
word that means underworld in uh in
magachi culture and so he's trying to
find uh the gate
that connects the world of the living
and the will of the death
and
the second actor ramallah is a malagasy
a girl that is caught in
this story because of circumstances
and uh is caught
because of alexander's action inside
this mansion that is hidden deep in the
woods of madagascar
and so there's uh what you play as two
character and there's a lot of
ethical choice that you have to do to
make there's a lot of
puzzles uh
but basically um alexander is trying to
go deeper into the mansion to find this
gate to the underworld and ramallah is
trying to
escape
this uh this mention of power so
basically that's that's a little bit of
the setup of both character
what's interesting is that
you play both character in on the same
timeline timeline but the action that
you make as one character affects
the
consequences of another character so
once you play with that character so you
could be switching between two
characters and decisions that you make
stay consistent
uh within uh
the timeline of the other characters so
for example if you take something as one
character or if you break something
or if you leave a door open
then when you play as a second actor all
those things are going to remain
as is in the world so that's a little
bit of the the the unique selling point
of this game uh
if you guys remember if you played whole
game like resident evil 1
where you played both character when you
play as one character and then the
second everything is perfectly cooled
locked and you have to be playing in an
alternate
uh kind of uh similar world but
for this game every every action that
you make is gonna
stay persistent
in that persistent state as you switch
between two characters so that's
uh so
oh i was just gonna say so as you you're
switching them
like in different parts of the story or
as you like if you beat the game and
then you play you replay it it maintains
the integrity of what happened before
so basically yeah there is three chapter
a chapter for alexander a chapter for
ramallah and then a final chapter
where uh you alternate between the the
two characters but
so uh when you play as alexander you're
gonna make decisions some of them
ethical decision because
um
and that's also going to expect you know
the path that you're going to take at
the ending
and then when you switch the second
chapter as ramallah
then those all the action
the consequences
of those actions
is that if that makes sense
no that totally makes sense i i felt a
rumbling feature on the controller as
[Laughter]
the default uh
unity ui um
text base though
but uh
yeah so now we're working on this first
section of dimension which is basically
the the main hall of the basement and
also the dungeon
could you talk a little bit as we still
play um
number one is he going in the right is
he doing the right thing
go back
i'm doing i know
yeah and also you can run uh if you hold
down the x button i believe if you have
an xbox controller
it's either the x button yeah there you
go
uh
to the right there's a should be a door
on the right
side of that room
turn right again on the right side of
here oh okay
yeah just gonna run into the car
i can't say anything because if i was
playing
me the whole time yeah
it's pretty funny
could you talk a little bit about your
team
and you could you could interrupt and
just jump in and tell them where to go
too but uh yeah they take that rope uh
there's a little bit of uh
text there but
it's okay um
so my team is a little bit scattered all
over the world
one of the main people person that that
stayed with me with my previous game is
ayaka
nakamura who is based in japan
so yeah you can attach the rope here and
you have to go back near the throne to
put um there should be a lever near the
throne if you go back
no not that way the other
not the other way
yeah this should be a tron like just go
for it
and the uh yeah that lever up here yeah
yeah okay write that down
though the puzzle elements are really
cool it's interesting
yeah i saw the attachment
japan she's the one doing the the
concept art and also all the promo
promotional art for the game
of course me myself i'm taking care of
the design the programming
and
obviously the the production
a little bit of level art as well
then we have uh mark choi who's based in
um
london he's the one doing the
composition music composition
we have ahmed who is also in montreal
he's doing the sound
we have
a
steam of stephanie laundry that does the
character modeling
so uh i'm pretty much the one
full time on this but uh and other
members come in and out to do their job
and
i'm
the one integrating everything
into the game
uh so yeah we're pretty much
scattered all over the world
that's that's cool what were what were
some of the lessons you learned from
your first game that you brought over to
developing this game
because i know there must be
there must be a ton right there is a
ton of lesson um i guess
the main one is uh
not rushed into it like um i i have more
of a philosophy of you know it's gonna
be finished when it's gonna be finished
uh i want to put more you know care and
attention to into this
uh oh you have to go back to the chest
oh did you get the munch
yeah he got it okay
so go back to the candle near the table
get to the right yeah
and uh
here in case you missed it i can give
you the solution you have to take the
the knife on the right side
if you move with the d-pad
yeah so take hold of the knife
and put one on the chest
oh wow this is really gruesome
one on the right hand uh
the right right arm
yeah
yeah
and one on the left
leg
oh wow
uh not left leg please
oh left leg
okay
yeah you can take it back yeah
take it
i thought he said i thought you said
left neck too
okay sorry about it
i'm
[Laughter]
yeah there should be this device
right there
oh wow
uh no go back
uh yeah to the left
to the right
yeah
there
okay
that's
interesting so what are your
obviously this has some survival horror
influences what are some of your main
influences for this game and other games
that your studio is developing
well uh
i've always been a fan of the scion
silent hill series
and
fatal frame
still
in terms and of course resident evil so
those are were my main inspiration
but in terms of um storytelling uh
a lot of it from is from like uh puzzle
game from like zero escape series and
things like that
uh
it's less there's less action it's more
about the puzzles about uh you know in
the the vein of escape room and stuff
like that
but there is a little bit of action
oh that's interesting i haven't played
the zero escape series that's i gotta
check that out now
yeah it's really good
yeah you're going the right way yeah
so what are some of the challenges that
you faced you know um developing this
game
um
there is challenge but i would say it's
it's kind of challenge that are fun to
overcome so
a lot of it is uh research you know to
to make sure that i have uh in terms of
like uh finding out monster like for
example you'll see a monster
uh soon
a lot of
that information is um
not written down on
in documents so
uh a lot of the work was to like
interview people um you know families on
you know uh
stuff like that and if it is documented
in books it's usually very uh hard to
find on on the internet so i had to like
hunt down
um
on the internet like you had to go to
the library
i have to go to the library
stop playing video games and actually
you know open a book and uh
you know order books that are that have
like one print left in the world or
things like that
like for example here here's a monster
called the kinoli
which uh
is a monster that
which
that used to be human but was possessed
by a human
evil human spirit for such a long time
that
they changed their appearance changed to
something like this or
a creature with very not long nails and
um
that's cool i can imagine uh just the
discovery
um during your research would be quite
fun especially during development and
it's like real like
real history that you're digging into it
seems really interesting where can we
find out more about the game when is
when are you
anticipating release and and where can
we follow you in the game this game's
dumb
so uh you can uh i really recommend you
guys to follow our mailing list on our
website which is flyingcarpetsgames.com
so you should be able to uh
you know register to our mailing list
there's we're also on um
on steam wishlist if you want to wish
this to us
so we're gonna send information updates
through uh steam and also through our
mailing list so those would be the the
two
main way to to get
to follow us
of course our twitter is is a good place
as well
uh in terms of our plan uh i would
really like us to be able to
do a kickstarter either this year or the
start of next year
like i said i i want to put as much care
as possible into this game the the demo
that you saw today is maybe like uh 15
of the game
but
i i would really like to finish this
game within uh two years or something
like that
uh
but again you know learning from my past
game i
i i want to to come in
uh with the philosophy philosophy of
it's gonna be finished when it's gonna
be uh finished and not rush things and
make put as much air into it as possible
because
uh it is personal uh kind of personal
and also um
it reflects a culture that is not
usually uh presented in game and so i
want
uh to uh to be as accurate and as as
careful as possible when i
when the the game is released
thank you so much
we appreciate you yeah this is this is
thank you thank you so much for watching
it's a beautiful game yeah for sure
all right
all right talk to you later
that was dope you're really into those
games yeah you're like really into those
style of game games
you already knew the you were just like
memorizing all the puzzles that's it's
hilarious i was like struggling when i
first tried it i actually would have
benefited more from him walking me
through it um but yeah that was that was
really awesome hoboken go ahead and wish
list that that is on the mix steam page
right now as we speak up next
we have an award-winning producer and
developer des gale who is a founder of
poc and play been in the industry for 23
years worked at xbox ea independently on
his own games and helps developers at
publishing studio fellow traveler and so
much more dez will be sharing his game
hell brand and we do have a little piece
of uh
what is it uh we have a little animatic
an amazing animatic and then we're gonna
be playing an early build of the game
awesome check it out
that was incredible must have been 20 of
them
no at least 30 unbelievable but
why do you have to live they are just
villagers
there's no honor in that but we haven't
seen the action this whole journey we're
trying to fight
fear not there is plenty of fight for
you in here
this will stop any unwanted guests from
coming from behind
oh man this is one guy in here
there is nothing for you here
please leave
oh it's just a woman to hide here of all
places
genius
welcome home friedrich
can we attack
yes
formation 6 formation 6.
where is the boy
why are you doing this
i am a soldier i serve the crown
it is on the wrong head that is not up
to me
do not be a fool i taught you better
than this
better foolish than blind
where
is
the boy
even if you get through me you'll never
find him
you could be right then leave
[Music]
you're still a strong fighter
but age has got the best of you
maybe i won't need to find him maybe
he'll come to me
[Music]
[Applause]
okay it's okay
there we go hidden in plain sight
impressive magic you cannot do this you
know she will kill him
you may as well leave him here with me
he will never forgive you for this
this is for you
it's a shame the circumstances weren't
different
[Music]
that was the animatic for hell brand we
have des
on the line it looks really interesting
it's cool to see stuff
uh so early you know what i mean
especially story based narrative
you there dez
i am hello yo
how are you doing
yeah good thanks
um it's really funny what's that
again um yeah we haven't looked it
internally for like good feel for months
now um
but uh
it's a good asset to help us like pitch
for funding um
yeah that's pretty cool
i i think that that's even like a good
like way to start i mean because you
have we have an early build of the game
you have the animatic
there's so much actually i would love to
talk to you about because you have such
a wealth of knowledge and you're a
veteran in the space can we like let's
just
get started with a little bit of your
history i mean
because but you know before prepping for
this and i know i've known you for a bit
i mean just through talking a few times
and looking at some of your interviews
it's crazy what you have accomplished so
i kind of want to have the the audience
hear some of that can you tell us a
little bit about your your your
background in the industry
cool yeah absolutely um oh man
so yeah i started a long time ago uh
1998
i
got my first job with lego
before they were called um
we were making games like lego right
race is actually pretty good um on the
on the ps1
um
and we did like lego uh lego lad lego
creator on on uh pc
uh the couple of uh game boy games
actually which was pretty cool
um
yeah after that uh i went to microsoft
for a little bit helped launch the
original xbox
um that was very
intense time um but still good uh when i
got from there there i went to ea after
that for five years um yeah that was
awesome like you know worked on pretty
much every ea sports title under the sun
um
then i left there went into sort of like
smaller development um
still working on ea games which is which
is kind of funny
um
popped over to barcelona for a bit made
some mobile games for adidas
uh
then i went home
and what did i do oh yeah i went to work
for climax on a game
um that got killed by square
and then um
just to show how small the industry is
the bizarre twist of fate i ended up
working for square
uh with the two people that actually
killed my previous game so um
it was cool like
the game was ambitious and uh honestly
yeah we weren't getting there like it
could have ended better but um
objectively it was the right decision
like you know there's no beef there um
and then yeah that's what i switched
into sort of like indie publishing so
i uh
what i do see i was a producer of life
is strange the original
series did i moved on to just cause
four i think
yeah three four one of them um and after
that yeah i moved into publishing with
the collective team
that was cool uh published some really
nice games
and then uh
after that
i came over here built a house yeah and
then um i started working with fellow
traveler um two and a half years ago
yeah focusing on narrative games which
is great because that's kind of like uh
the core for me um
yeah
that's awesome that that's so i mean
you're like super og triple og status
and i don't think yeah i don't think
people know that that's that's crazy
um so so you're working with a fellow
traveler and you're you're developing
prototypes and uh various different
games
um which kind of brings us to hell brand
you want to jump into describing hell
brandon maybe help help alfonso out um
and he's gonna he's gonna hit me real
soon if i keep clowning him
so yeah you need to walk back and come
out the river that's right and then go
where are you
yes you go back to the main pathway you
go with a bridge you'll be fine yeah um
so the hell brand yeah uh
the hell brand as you can see it's like
an action rpg and it kind of follows the
story
of uh this fallen king
so um
you made a deal with the devil that
you'd stay in hell as long as your son
was alive and um
that adamatic is kind of like the path
to your son not being alive um so you
get released from hell and um
basically you're on a journey of
vengeance um you want to find out what
happened and uh
you know retrieve your son's body um
but the devil makes you another deal
she's just like oh hey tell you what if
you bring his body back to me i'll bring
it back to life but i need you to get
this ancient artifact for me
so um
yeah you travel the sort of like
the world doesn't have a name yet but to
go to these different places and you
need to collect um
uh graces which are
a mixture of powers
and different armor that you used to
have back when you were outside of hell
um because you're gonna need to take
down the big bad at the end um
the the little wrinkle here is those
gracies are protected by guardians um
who are a mixture of um
mythical creatures that have been imbued
with god-like powers uh to help them
protect it um
yeah
yeah it's good fun uh cool cool are we
does this current build have like music
or sound just i'm just kidding to make
sure that we have everything
yeah we'll just okay
okay cool
yeah we had some problems optimization
so like the the f like when the audio in
the file size is like huge
um
yeah we're not quite sure what we did
there no that totally that totally makes
sense
where are you guys where are you at with
development
i'll go ahead so yeah what's good so
sorry if you go back to that gate
um to the
yeah if you go all the way back um
oh we'll see i think it's left bumper or
a right bumper you can uh cast fire
magic and you should open the gate and
if that doesn't work i can take
somewhere else um where are we at so
we've just come to the end of
uh
this proof of concept so
we're very lucky um we applied
so yeah sorry look honestly
yeah so you need to talk to the green
character
if you press uh what's the controller b
yeah good
um yeah he'll ask you to like the
brazier and then that's when you press
that fire attack and it should light
um
so yes we've got concept funding um
which is literally just the right design
dot from the
state
there we go
okay that didn't work um if you come a
little bit back down the path
and then now come around to your like to
your
if you turn right and on your right my
left that's it yeah and then
there we go go through there they go
sorry the opposite way so i would have
this is the camera as well
the other side of the path let's go that
way
yeah keep keep just going just go down
i'm just going
[Laughter]
cool there we go keep going you'll find
a path around there that'll let you into
town um
so yes sorry so yes we've worked on this
for um uh nine months uh yeah this is
the proof of concept that we uh are
going to use to pitch for further
funding
that's cool that's cool this is
beautiful yeah it's great
visually i think this is like so so for
all the audience out here like we just
got this a couple days ago so it's it's
actually awesome to see
like builds like early so i i can't
front on if i was doing the same thing i
would be going like in the middle into
trees and walls and everything else so
um
it's that's hilarious
i think it was uh what is it
oh really okay
yeah look not to the right but like into
town the other way yeah
oh
well
that's not good all right this is the
problem of live streams oh no
yeah you got fumbled up uh
if you've got a
keyboard a reset press
up and you can teleport
um if you have a keyboard
um yeah we'll just reset we'll just
reset it it's cool
no no that's all it's all good all right
can you talk about like so you said you
had some funding for oh you got it he
got it i think
um
so you said you got some funding for
like the to to put together the game
design document and and
um
the
the preliminary document this dude is
like
falling down
uh mountain like mountains like crazy
this is ridiculous i think we should
just reset it honestly
yeah let's do it
let's go
let's go to uh
two up you know i mean okay yeah two up
reset you know
this is great
the the funding yeah so the german
government um
they're really committed to uh like
raising german game developers um
on the world stage uh so there's kind of
two tiers you've got the main sort of
like federal government funding um
which has one pot of like x millions and
then each state has its own different
funding pots as well which
um they go up to about half million in
some places it's very similar to the
canadian media fund
which is very cool so you've got a
concept stage which you can ask for
uh 20 000 euros that's literally you
write design doc
do some concept art um
which we did
and then after that you can apply for
follow-on funding which for us they call
it um prototype funding which we've used
to create this proof of concept here
um
and that go we got 80 000 for that um
which is cool but
80 000 disappears very
very quickly um
yeah people yeah some people don't
realize how how costly
even making like prototypes is you know
so it's it's interesting can you talk a
little bit about your philosophy
on raising funds because
you when i've talked to you uh
previously you have a very interesting
you know way of going about it right and
and kind of mitigating your risks
so
it's
it's oh man it's kind of frustrating so
for me personally like my risk profile
is very high like i think you know video
games
you know they're definitely an art form
and some games
whilst they aspire to be commercial like
i don't think that's always the end goal
um
so i um oh man how did you do that
so
what we tend to do is like before that
like we got the funding here is we do a
little bit of work for hire um screwing
away a little bit of money and then we
just work on you know some concepts and
prototypes um
there is a little bit of like market
analysis where we're just like okay
these types of games we definitely
shouldn't do
um
you know and this is it's sad actually
because my favorite type of game like
you know 3d platformers but
they're very difficult to sell if your
name is nintendo um
yeah and then uh specifically for us
like because we're heavily story based
you know i i tend to
come up with the
division and the core story arc like oh
that's kind of what i want to do and
then that's what i bring on like proper
writers uh and they they make it not
terrible um
and then yeah i like with this this
proof of concept here like
this actually but my trend a little bit
because i prefer to sort of like have
all the environment just all grey boxed
and then just focus on the control the
camera and the the character
but um
uh
this could sound really negative but it
isn't but
as part of the funding like you have to
hire from specific places in germany um
and basically we just played the
strengths of the people that we could
find um
so yeah that's what kind of skewed the
prototype slightly um
but then yeah in general with funding
like obviously the goal is to try and
get as much free money as possible um
take their grant funds first and then
speak to platform holders
and then if you still need money after
that
uh that's when you start talking to
publishers um
you know because each terms you know
just get less and less attractive um
yeah
that's that's super interesting i don't
know if this is where he's supposed to
go but it's amazing
yeah you're right good out this is good
oh okay that was really good because i
was i was just looking at how everyone
was doing uh that's that's really funny
um
one of the questions i uh so you've
worked with publishers you work with big
aaa companies in what ways
have uh working for a publisher
influenced your growth as a developer
and a leader in the industry and your
path
oh cool um
i guess
uh knowing
what sort of like internally the
processes are so
um
when you when you're making the pitch
materials um you know focusing on some
areas over other areas um and knowing
you just have to be specific
so
uh publicly like some publishers are
very clear about what they want and what
their labels are about um others aren't
so much a bit more difficult but um the
conversations just happen much more
faster when you do that
um
and also uh the biggest thing is not to
assume
i mean you know unless you're in the
upper echelon of of superstardom um
don't assume that
who you're pitching to knows who you are
what you've done like always be clear
about going over that again
um
and then
and some of this is just kind of um
you know direct insider knowledge is
that sometimes it's just budgets around
when they've just got to spend the money
um
sadly for me it doesn't always line up
the types of games that we make but um
yeah you know but it's you know they're
annual they need to be you know they
need to be um allocated otherwise you
don't get them again next year
um
yeah and then i think the biggest thing
is just knowing that
you know there's always more than one
person you need to convince
um
pretty much every published i've had
contact with um
you know you meet the person like the
scout or or the best deaf person
but after that like you know there's
four or five other people they got
convinced internally uh before they give
it a thumbs up or a thumbs down so
uh yep there's that and the main thing
is just patience like seeing it from the
inside like i know how long things take
um
you know it's not gonna be a week or two
sometimes it could be six or even eight
but that depends on how much they like
your game right like everyone likes the
game they'll move as fast
yeah
yeah that's that's an interesting thing
that i've i've like encountered too i've
also encountered because i i do stuff in
publishing too
the lat even though the game is dope as
hell
even if like if a developer is impatient
it kind of puts people off it's like yo
just
relax a bit you know just wait it out
i'm trying to help help you i'm trying
to work with you and that that kind of
that could also turn publishers off
i've
i've um
yeah i've witnessed people talk
themselves out of a deal
and you're just like holy [ __ ] all you
just gotta do is can i stare
yeah all you gotta do is like you know
shut the f up and uh you'll be right but
yeah some people yeah
yeah it's hilarious yo thank you dez uh
his
it's really cool to see this early on
thank you for sharing it with us and
thanks for joining us we have to have
another longer information like another
conversation because you have so much
information we just have to chop it up
but uh where can we find out more about
hell brand um
cool um so yeah we may be on twitter a
little bit quieter in the middle but um
that's on
hidden titan d e
um maybe shout out there uh the steam
page is up so you can wish this to game
right now please um and then for me like
i'm at kid deserve on on twitter if you
want to see me
mainly [ __ ] post and occasionally talk
about the game
that's a that's hilarious
uh cool thank you so much dez i think
we're gonna go into a short break and
then um we're gonna come back with a
friend of ours john davis
from black sheep consulting so thank you
so much dez thank you
yeah for sure for sure
right
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
and we're back
yeah dezz's game is is amazing you did a
great job because that was like one of
the first times you've tried that and uh
fell off a cliff a couple times what
made things happen next up we got i'm
not even giving you a chance to rebuttal
you know what i mean
i was looking at mary back there she was
like what the hell is this guy doing uh
but i wouldn't have done any better um
so up next or up right now what am i
talking about john davis
co-founder of bit summit black sheep
consulting he does so many things he's
on the line what's up what's going on
what's up what's up
how are you doing going on
uh man i'm hanging in there man i've
been i had to get up pretty early it's
like 6 6am in tokyo right now so uh
i was fortunate my my daughter was like
she she she woke me up at four she was
like daddy you have a you have a meeting
at five
wow
that's crazy she's your assistant
already
i know all right
that's cool no but it's it's really
sorry there's a little there's a tiny
there's a little bit of a delay so like
i think we'll have to just maybe leave a
little a pregnant pause
um okay we'll have to
be we'll have to be like the uh the uh
uh you know that guy on the scene that
the you know
for whenever he's reporting you know
from overseas he's just waiting just
sitting here that's what it's like i
have to have fun just sitting there for
a second
yeah just like this okay cool
yeah um but no it's awesome to have you
on you know on board i've been trying to
have you like on one of the black voices
gave me for a minute you know but then i
cut like the last time i i caught kovid
right when we were supposed to do a
stream which was unfortunate
you know um
but it's great to have you here i mean
you're such you're so influential in the
in the space with bit summit your work
at previous convention stuff i know i'm
blowing you up but you you have to toot
your own horn a little bit uh can you
just talk about like the thing because
you have black sheep uh consulting and
you're you're producing you're working
on a lot of different games with a lot
of folks and also it's not easy to
get in line with and in tune with um
folks you know japanese developers and
publishers like that's something you
have to really work your way up to so
can you talk a little bit about your
journey
yeah yeah yeah so um
my kind of origin story was you know i
came out to japan to teach english uh
and and
with under the auspices that i would i
would kind of uh freelance you know uh
in journalism
and um that was right before that was
like around 2004 you know so it was a
few years before the whole kind of
world kind of crashed with the great
recession
and uh um and i was just here kind of
freelancing a little bit for ign for
families and stuff met some nice people
and um and kind of slowly worked my way
through journalism into helping out um
game devs here and helping out you know
publishers here and things like that
which led to me working at like
grasshopper manufacturer um working at q
games
and at q games uh i i work with uh james
milkey to to start this summit
nice that's dope but how did that how
did you start because you know when when
we first met i did not know that you
originally started with j and i love
james too like he's gonna be here in the
in the city i think he's gonna be djing
and playing music which is which is
crazy how did you guys like come
together and and start form bit summit
well we kind of ran in the same circle i
mean the the the foreigners that work in
games here in japan it's very small you
know small group of us and and we we you
know had a lot of friends in common and
um and right after i joined q games you
know we went out for lunch and he was
like hey i'm leaving q entertainment
to come work at cue games
and uh the two of us were there and we
had just finished um i think shipping a
pixel jump 4 a.m
and um and we had some free time and he
was like hey let's let's let's do a
convention and i was kind of like what
are you talking about you know like what
do you want to do and he's like i want
to just a little bit different than
than you know your typical typical stuff
i'm going to like do something that
really highlights japanese indies here
um and yeah we we got together with uh
with tomisan uh uh one of the producers
at q and and just kind of started
brainstorming and had our first event
like maybe six months after that we had
about 200 people you know uh a total
um it was it was dope though because you
know famitsu came out um
we had ign came out we had a lot of
people um from from
overseas that showed us love you know
thanks to the strength of of q and milky
and uh and it was really kind of the
springboard
to to making the show a lot bigger and
it's just every year it's been just like
just like you guys this is our 10th year
anniversary here for good summit so
you know it's it's uh it's kind of been
a blessing you know
i didn't imagine it was definitely
it's crazy it's like you know going to
bid summit is definitely a destination
event
that everyone should go to and it's just
like i love going it sucks the two years
that that we couldn't uh do anything or
we couldn't go out because i missed
going out there it's like in the in
kyoto it's it's just gorgeous so you
know definitely props on that i know you
were writing some notes so you want to
jump in yeah i mean one of the things i
want to know is like how did you how do
you find other devs of color community
obviously in japan there's not you know
like a plethora of
black people there so
so how are you connecting with with
folks
uh it's it's like i said very small
community so anybody that that works in
game dev here you know a dev of color
here you know
we will run into each other
unfortunately i've been stuck in this
office for like the past two years
um and and
not really able to like get out and
press the flesh and kiss the babies you
know to really get to to know people but
but you you kind of just run into the
same folks at events you know people
come to bit summit they go to tokyo
indies they go to kyoto indies these
like you know kind of small community
events
and you see we see somebody and you just
you know give them to give them the nod
you know the heads up and then uh you
know and try to build from there um you
know my homie from i did i've known for
forever um
scott scott burford's got more scott
popular as his his kind of uh his
moniker but
you know he he
he uh he he started in you know just
developing his own game kind of like in
a very small sense
um and and so you just kind of run into
these people um it's it's not something
that that
it's something you kind of actively have
to do you know there's also facebook
groups things like that
but uh but yeah there's definitely a
very small
small community here of of game devs of
color
yeah it seems to be this the the theme
with a lot of the developers we talked
to is that you have to build community
you have to connect with people you have
to make an effort to like sort of like
cultivate that network and i think it
people who are successful are the ones
who are actually
actively engaging with people and
not that you can't not be successful not
doing that but it just seems to like be
a catalyst for it um one of the other
things i was like wanted to like know
about is like i know the gaming scene is
different in japan um and i heard that
you guys there's still like
straight up coin operated stuff like
arcades don't exist here anymore like
they just don't exist in in the states
is that still a thing there
uh game centers arcades are are
are not really a thing anymore like when
i got here 18 years ago you could still
go
down to uh to you know the corner and
find
game centers right like arcades and you
know go there and play marvel vs capcom
and
things like that um there but now
they're just like just a really a few
handful of places that are kind of
really gg you know uh um
uh uh fgc
um kind of oriented fighting game
community oriented so you know you have
a place a spot in shibuya you have a
spot and you know you give a girl what
not where people who are like
are in the scene who want to you know
fight other people are going to be there
otherwise it's just just your your
regular like kind of like photo booth
stuff your your
um
more claws yeah gotcha ponds um i don't
know dave and buster's is still a thing
in the states but but more event spaces
like that
yeah
yeah
then really even arcades anymore i mean
worldwide you know and that's that's
kind of the thing for for a bit some of
this years are our uh our tagline is
crossroads is that you know everything
is is really shifted in the past
i mean obviously in the past you know 10
20 years and yeah and this year has been
there's been it's just like this kind of
sea change
for the way that people interact and and
um
through games um so you don't have these
a lot of these physical spaces everybody
has moved online
um and it can be disconcerting you know
for you know old heads like me you know
um like where
what am i supposed to do where do we go
so we want to kind of like be an avenue
for the japanese devs here and also the
devs that you know expat devs like
myself
to be able to to
navigate that space that online space
but also be able to
to be
um
in an event physically because i think
it's important to be able to talk to
people and and you know really present
your personality in a way that's not
just a screen name
um so we have to like this is just
little crossroads here right now that's
going on in games and then and i guess
the world in general
that we're all trying to navigate you
know
yes that's interesting because like you
know just gdc
no one was coming to gdc
and then all of a sudden a few it like
trickled down it became this domino
effect now everybody's coming to gdc
because they just want to see people in
person
uh which is just an interesting
phenomenon um and actually like what
you're talking about is like that's what
i when i would go to
akubar akubara i'm i'm i know i'm busy
but like every akihabara yeah see i'm
like sounding like it's like it's
terrible middle eastern or some [ __ ] um
it's terrible um but i would always want
to go to electric city that's my way of
of uh not butchering it anymore um and
just play games against people you know
and like just because i'm a big fighting
game fan obviously um
and just you know even in tokyo like the
the taito game center and the sega game
center and from what i heard a lot of
those have been shutting down but that
was like a really good treat because
they don't have those in-person things
here anymore um yeah can you talk a
little bit about like
uh about black sheep and what you've
been because i would you know i would
see you at pax and you're like
representing all these different
companies you're doing production can
you talk about kind of like what you've
been doing in the
uh in the game industry
well i left i left q and i think 2015
maybe and uh because i was i was living
i was living in tokyo and working for
them remotely
um and uh and i left cuda to work with
the mega booth for a while and when i
started working with the mega booth it
just kind of became more of a consulting
thing where i was helping them
with all of their stuff in asia indie
mega booth by the way um and
um from there it just kind of kind of
naturally happened you know where i
would i was helping
other japanese devs that were trying to
to get their games overseas and then and
then also helping any
uh devils from overseas that were trying
to get their games into japan just kind
of like introducing people to the right
folks you know working with publishers
working with developers
um
through bit summit as well i was going
to to different you know different
countries uh you know
through our partnerships with other
other events you know like the mix or or
indicate or
um
uh
big in brazil
um just just all these different places
so it kind of kind of happened evolved
naturally um like if you if you go and
like look online for like black sheep or
something like that my for my company
like i don't have a web page or anything
like that you know i'm pretty low-key i
just i just uh just try to work with
folks that work in projects that i like
and and i've been fortunate enough to to
uh
to survive
off of that
i feel that for sure that's it's very
it's actually very similar to like the
stuff that we're doing with black voice
and gaming in the mix is like you just
start to connect people to different
places just naturally and like not
really looking for a paycheck just just
to help out the community
you know at large and then it just so
happens you get fitted and you start to
have these relationships kind of like us
connecting and like hey let's do this
maybe we could do this maybe we could do
business together and it becomes this
natural thing because you know you're
you're so passionate about this space
that it just naturally evolves to you're
like making a living
making a living yeah yeah i mean it's
it's
super i'm super fortunate super blessed
about it you know like i like when i was
going to mix events you know at pax and
in gdc
and linked up with you you know i
remember we had lunch we were like all
right let's do something and then you
know like a year passed and then i think
i came out to e3 one year and then like
you gave me a big like shout out when
you guys are like finishing the show
you're like yeah we're going to get
something to put you on the black oh
sweet yeah yeah all right
and uh and then and then we had you guys
out so just kind of just you know you
have to to work with the people that are
around you people that you feel like are
you know good folks and and kind of
um uh
i don't know it it just evolves right
it's it's i think we're all very
fortunate to be working in this space
and be working with something that we
obviously have a passion for and love
doing
and uh and and yeah hopefully it
continues
[Laughter]
we survived a pandemic so
yeah we made it i mean i think that one
of the things that's
super great about when we talk about
community and building that community is
the connections that um justin has done
has built um with the black voices in
gaming like all of these developers that
we feature on this program um
are connecting with each other and i
think that that it's it's building this
really organic community that is is
really really benefiting everybody
yeah yeah i ran into desks like like and
i think i met desmond like in like
berlin
like
like a few years ago
you know like you just run into people
in the in like crazy places
you know
um
but uh but you gotta nurture those
connections that would if if i had any
advice for for any any game devs of you
know of color or otherwise like like you
have to kind of keep nurturing
your connections with people um and and
don't burn bridges you know just just
uh
cherish the relationship that you build
because they will they will guide you in
the future you know
that's my old man knowledge
that's yeah no that's i mean that's a
good way to take it out i was actually
gonna be i was about to ask you that
question and i think it's really funny
is because we were kind of talking ish
like a couple weeks ago
weeks ago about some folks that we've
talked with before and we're like damn
i'm just trying to like
talk to you or be cool with you and then
you're like burning this bridge for no
reason but it's like it kind of you know
it creates this trajectory of like now i
don't want to mess with these certain
people so and i think also as black
folks we got to really make sure our
reputation is sterling you know
it's like see you can't do that you
gotta maneuver in such a way
uh this is interesting but like how can
we find out more about you
uh more about bit summit and the things
that you're doing
uh yeah um i guess the best way would
just be to go to bitsuma.org uh for all
game devs uh you know submissions are
now open
uh they closed on uh april 15th
um and the show is going to be uh august
5th through the 7th
of this year and it's it's open to the
public this year so we're super happy
about that we're going to have one day
of um
just biz dev stuff and then one day of
public um where we're hoping and praying
that there's not a big
you know another big omicron surge or
another grandpa covert surge and that
will come kill travel again
uh but uh yeah we're we want to have the
mix out of course um and and as many
game devs as possible especially game
days of color i want to you know say
what's up to my people so come out
enjoy the show have some drinks by the
river after the show and uh yeah make
some friends
yes so we hope to come out soon um but
thanks so much john
it was thank you
so
appreciate it and we'll talk to you soon
thank you all right all right
peace
john is so is just so dope chill yeah um
just making things happen next up we
have a developer uh oh he's still on
there okay great
clowning uh we're gonna be chatting with
yada anderson um
from synergia games and play eldoran
uh where you can explore a dangerous
world and fight deadly creatures for
untold treasure in this love crafty
inspired action rpg game let's check out
the trailer right now
[Music]
that was the trailer for elder and the
game looks dope i actually was playing
this game for hours while we were
testing um and i got hooked i love
action rpgs and sprite based games uh
with amazing pixels we have yada on the
line and we're going to be playing elder
and not elder rings
um so let's let's make it happen what's
up yada
hey
what's up guys
how's it going
yes nice i'm so so happy so exciting you
know
thank you so much for the opportunity to
you know talk about this project and
i was watching the the
you know the talk it was nice also to to
hear yeah
yeah i'm not i'm i'm seriously telling
you the truth the game is super fun like
we were here because we were supposed to
have you again before before i i caught
covet and i we were like setting
everything up and i just kept playing
the game every while everyone was like
testing the stream and the mechanics
feel so good and like just the aspects
of loving your character up are
really really fun so you you've really
made something nice can you talk
about you know your team
where you're at in the world because
obviously you're not um in the states
and it's interesting to see
uh and talk to folks globally
exactly i mean nice to hear that you
guys uh like the the experience
um you know
that's what uh
in the industry is about you know the
community that the hope everybody can
you know
cannot enjoy this this industry yeah i'm
from brazil uh the salvador is in the
state of malia
and
yeah i'll do my best with my english i
mean i can hear better than understand
but as i'm talking about more about the
art stuffs
i can you know
i mean i can do it's better i mean
so
uh our team
basically all of us we are you know
uh
from different places
of course we are working uh i mean
remotely like you know online
yeah even
uh
before the the this you know pandemia's
things but
yeah
i mean we are almost
around six
five or six guys you know working on it
we have the director
and the
knee and his art
guy in animation
um
the guy in the sound and two or three
guys the doing the the code stuffs
so yeah oh cool what so what role do you
play on the team
yeah i'm the artist
oh okay
awesome awesome
what what can you talk a little bit
about the influences um that you've had
that help you develop this style of game
yeah of course uh
i this is my first speaks a lot ever
you know
uh oh wow that's crazy yeah i came from
the advertising uh industry i'm
illustrator and graphic designer
and but i but i i started to to doing
some you know concept art uh
i mean for my own by myself
and uh the director saw my work on the
internet and and he he said yeah this
guy can can give me what i want but he
he have no
pixel art job at all
and uh he called me and said hey what
about this i have this game i
i i see
you're working i like it but you know
you have no pixel art in your
and
he asked me if i want to try
and then i start to you know
yeah give him a week and then google it
and
you know start to to learn and read and
try something and then we start this guy
the director he is a really talented guy
he has a lot of
reference and he have a you know a
good and clear idea about what he wants
and that's why it was possible
he stayed beside me and said this is
what i want
that's the way that's the reference and
so
uh we could do this
so that's my first that's that's super
good
that's crazy too it's awesome i think
that's kind of a the hustle of a lot of
indies is if you don't know how to do it
you figure out how to do it right and
that's very admirable
uh admirable i i'd like muffled that one
um
that's cool can you tell us about and
run us through the game like the story
and and and what alfonso is doing
dying yeah
perfect uh this is a lovely crafting
world base
[Laughter]
and
of course
we can the the base of the the structure
is
the
[Music]
i mean this guy he's a guy he's a
scenario i don't know the name in
english
but you know people who
work for money whatever it is
and
yeah this guy have a some contract with
you know
you know another girl and maybe big boys
one
and it will happen some you know plot
twist between the game basically
and then you know we've got a lot of uh
universe to explore we have a lot of uh
um
it's all about uh you know
she wanted him in english
man um
can go because
it's missing a lot of uh
words
no
i'm sorry it's all good
no no it's all good
it's cool to hear about the world
building and some of the the structure
and some of the monsters and
um where did some of the ideas for
this i know it's lovecraftian but some
of the monsters and and uh
threats you face in the game
yeah basically uh we
i mean we want to give the to the
players uh some classical structure of
course i have all of us have all those
kind of reference you know it's kind of
monster i we are always looking for the
big one the nice one you know uh
when we're developing the the director
wants of of course it needs to to work
on the game as a
in a
level design point of view but
uh
we also want to give to people some
classical experience you know classical
monster classical
um
you know
creatures
but at the same time with some
originality so that's the balance we are
always looking for
uh we have some i mean a huge ones on
this game
i think there's some small ones but
i i can say this always about if it's
fixed or not in the mechanic stuff
something like this and of course it is
you have the mood of what the crafting
uh i mean
world you know uh creature those kind of
aesthetics
that's that that's the
main guide
what so this is this is your first is
this your first game because you're
talking about you were in graphic design
and
in illustration yeah yeah that's my
first one in pixel art i did i did
another one but it's still um finishing
but it was more
yeah more more more cartoony uh
kind of fantasy cartoony stylish the
additional painting is more
uh
this one was my first pixel art it was
really really um
you know difficult to get in this world
understand how the whole thing is you
know we said it i mean all those
because i i i designed the
the those sprite sprite kits you know
and then
the developers start to develop the
those uh rooms and then we back and take
a look and see it's working and then
back again so it's really new process
for me
but i i love it what
oh no i was just gonna say since you you
kind of hustled through this figuring
out how to do pixel art and design what
kind of advice would you give
young developers just trying to get into
game development
yeah i mean i'll try to
a point of view for
development
ah man be helpful i mean i studied with
a guy i mean
uh
he always told this
uh
[Music]
be helpful to try your best
i mean
because
in the industry i mean
really small teams trying to do our best
and
if you have a lot of skills it will help
you to be the project and help the
project now so in the development point
of view
try to have uh it's not about being
generalized it's about
uh
being able to help any kind of projects
in the
many ways
as an
artist man it's difficult because
i mean gaming is a serious thing
really seriously yeah
anything you do is
it needs a high quality
independent of the style
so as an artist you must have
the ability to keep the quality and the
structure i have to design all those
creatures environments
props
and everything
uh need to keep the level and
the style is not easy
so as an artist
yeah
be prepared to uh you know
a really
high challenge you gotta hustle
yeah that makes sense
um
yeah i was i was also gonna ask like
it's crazy it's kind of like for this
journey on black voices in uh gaming
today we went around the world pretty
much
jon is in
uh japan
we had um someone in montreal we had
another developer in germany dez who's
been all over the world can you talk a
little bit about the development scene
in brazil
like how is the camaraderie and how how
does it play out
yeah i mean
we everybody know that we have been some
problem with our government and they
took off a lot of investments and you
know cultural and you know uh those kind
of stuffs
and it compromised uh
this industry here right now
but we were
kind of start to develop some good
things i believe here in brazil because
of uh because it's so
mixture
and we have a lot of talent guys here
you know
uh i always think that you you come from
a a
country or a city or a i mean a
structure with no too much money
it
it invites you all the time to be more
creative if not you can do nothing so i
believe that
we always have a potential
but
we are still no
working hard to start to to develop some
uh
name opposition in this industry
but yeah i mean with internet today
the whole world is just one so it's so
easy to
um
you know to study to look for reference
you know
uh yeah that's it i mean
today
today we are really optimists
and
i i believe that
yeah somehow in some way we'll do our
you know we'll have our
our identity also you know on this
industry maybe
yeah for sure what are the what do you
think the most
popular games are in in brazil right now
that that folks play
ah good points um
i mean in the
i mean let's talk about the those triple
a the elder rings
yes
yeah and
yeah
i believe
we
here in brazil
of the the the the type of players the
more about
[Music]
uh casual you know the hyper casual
players you know the the of course the
the this community
in
of uh
gamers yeah of course this exists but
i believe
we we really like football games
football yeah games like soccer
and
but i believe today
in the any place all the rain is
something that
everybody's talking about
yeah that's that's cool i was it was
kind of hilarious because before and i
knew eldering was coming out but then
when i
when we were playing today and it was
like eldoran it's like so close to
eldering i'm wondering if you guys are
gonna thinking about possibly changing
the name last minute or are you gonna
kind of
like utilize that to your advantage
[Laughter]
like to your advantage have you guys
talked about that
yeah good good point uh
i saw um
uh kind of
gif like maybe maybe mimi i don't know
the name in english but you know this
kind of joke with image
this one amazing there was a guy
and they took the logo and said elder
and that little heart
and then
and the rand and then they got to see
what and they started the the heart
stopped to to beat me and say elder ring
there was a kind of joke with this i
believe oh
i get it someone like made a
yeah someone made like a little meme
that's that's hilarious
yeah because i can see because i
that's funny because i could see people
like basically talking stuff about it be
like oh yeah these are they they're
trying to like use the name you're like
no man we've been working on this for
like four years
you know exactly that that's the point i
think we we have the name first because
we have more than seven years designed
this
seven years wow
i did not realize
that's crazy
yeah yeah
uh is it already on on the scene
it's already there that you know the the
so
and our director this guy is really good
with names so
he knew this name would work in in you
know
elder older
and land come on this is just not
surprising
mike dropped son no
yeah and we are surprised oh why doesn't
anybody use this name he's so so unique
and she was he was able you know she was
there so did he just use it so eldering
come on i don't know maybe
they caught us yeah that's hilarious yo
yeah that's funny but um yeah so where
can we find out more about uh eldoran
and your team and do you have any more
like um insight on when you're gonna be
releasing the game is dope yeah yeah we
are we already in the
uh sim
so guys please go there and wishlist is
wishlist and you know
uh we already have us a website uh
eldering.com
and of course
facebook twitter and those indie
community discord uh
yeah had it maybe yeah
for sure well thank you so much yada for
joining us we hope to talk to you soon
again and and please feel to reach feel
free to reach out we would love to work
with you on other stuff
yeah i mean thanks so much thank you
guys for the opportunity again so
yeah
we appreciate it it's a wonderful game
thank you we'll see you later
that was that was really dope you that
game is tough and i think you actually
were playing a loaded game so you were
like jumped into the middle of it yeah i
was like all right let's go you're
making you're making stuff happen um
we're gonna shout out to our partners
for today's show raw fury for helping us
get this series started um and funding
throughout the year playstation has been
amazing razer we have some other ones
popping in
what about the steam page alfonzo
definitely go to the same page the uh
the mixed theme page featuring the black
voices and gaming game titles check
those out also go ahead and buy those
titles and wish list the ones that are
not available um that definitely helps
the developers um and get some get some
check that box
what else are we that's hilarious again
i could still hear yada
what can people look forward to from
black voice in gaming this is i'm just
slapping this one no i mean i think
we're going to be looking forward to
basically
growing this community bringing it
together adding more developers of color
all over the world as you guys can see
from the show um
doing marketing doing uh streams for
those developers promoting their their
games
publishing their games so connecting
them with large aaa organizations and
then also producing our own titles
ourselves
so that's what you can expect from us
for sure
and then we also have the freshman class
which will be gathering some some dope
indies and doing another poster and
shirts and that type of thing showing
them love and working with with the
press on that special thanks
to wilmer sound we're in their beautiful
facility in berkeley this place is
amazing we set up shop here at the mix
team media one
allah joel in the corner mary in the
crevice i'm just kidding uh again my
name is justin woodward co-founder of
the mix black voices in gaming and also
um one of the advisors in the black game
developer fund and i am with my homie
alfonso
thank you for letting me be here with
you again also for sure it's it's been a
great day um you could follow black
voice and gaming at bvi gaming on
twitter check out the games on
blackvoicesgaming.org we are updating
lists constantly you can also follow the
mix on instagram and twitch at media
indiexchange on twitter at any exchange
and me
at icj man thank you for joining us we
will see you soon peace
[Music]
now
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you